- [Voiceover] In the last video,
Sal and I were talking about
the Civil War Battle of Antietam.
Antietam took place in
Maryland on September 17, 1862.
Just to briefly recap, Antietam was the
single, bloodiest day in American history.
Over 4,000 people died, and Antietam was a
signature victory in the
Civil War for the North,
for Abraham Lincoln, and the
forces of the United States.
One thing that was really
important about Antietam
was that Lincoln had been
waiting for a Union victory,
so that he could proclaim the
Emancipation Proclamation,
which was intended to be a
real morale blow to the South,
and also a signal to both
enslaved people in the South,
Northern Republicans who were
strongly in favor of
Abolition, the end of slavery,
and also the world, especially Europe,
that the Civil War had become
a fight to end slavery,
not just a fight to
keep the Union together.
I mentioned in the last
video that there were
two reasons why Antietam was so important,
the first being that it led
to the Emancipation Proclamation.
The second reason was
slightly related to that.
The eyes of the world were really on
the United States and on
the Civil War at this time.
Many people in Europe
were trying to decide
whether they should intervene
in the American Civil War.
Now, why would they do this?
I think the most important
reason that they would
do this is because the
South of the United States
supplied 75% of the world's cotton
at the beginning of the Civil War,
and so to major industrialized nations,
especially the United Kingdom,
cotton was the source of their prosperity.
They based their economy, in
part, around textile mills.
This is what England was known for.
During the Civil War, the
North blockaded the South,
which meant that they
used the ships of the Navy
to prevent supplies from getting in
or crops from getting out
of the American South.
If England can't get their cotton crops,
they might be in a whole lot of trouble
when it comes to textile manufacturing.
In fact, the Confederacy was counting
on having the support of Europe
in their rebellion
against the United States,
partly for this reason.
Now, there were other reasons why Europe
might have intervened
on behalf of the South.
One of these was that
Europe was traditionally
a highly classed society, and they had
a lot of sympathy for the way that the
South did things with
a wealthy planter class
similar to the monarchy
or the gentry in Europe,
which was in control of poor whites
and enslaved people of African descent.
Another reason was that
it was to the advantage
of Europe not to have such a strong nation
as the United States
operating in the Americas.
Remember that this is
the era of Imperialism,
the very beginning of Imperialism,
as countries like the United Kingdom
and France, Germany, and others in Europe
begin to look for colonies abroad,
and the United States had in 1820
proclaimed the Monroe Doctrine which said,
"Europe, keep out of the Americas.
We consider this our area of the world."
Dividing what had been the United States
into two smaller nations would probably
have worked out in their favor,
so Europe had these
social or cultural reasons
to join with the South and also
political, or perhaps
foreign policy reasons
to join with the South.
The South was really counting on
the intervention of a European nation.
They thought, certainly, the
United Kingdom would
intercede on their behalf.
It looked, especially
early in the Civil War,
like that might be the case,
but when it came down to it,
the United Kingdom did not
intercede for the South,
and there were a few
reasons why that happened.
One of those reasons was that the South
had kind of oversold cotton to England
in the years leading up to the Civil War,
so there was actually a
considerable supply on hand
which English merchants had built up
before the Civil War, kind
of seeing this coming.
The loss of new Southern cotton
really didn't turn out to be as
big of a problem, as many had imagined.
Related to that, as the
Civil War began to ramp up,
both Egypt and India, which
were also cotton producers,
began to increase their production,
understanding there
would be more of a demand
coming from England that couldn't
be supplied from the American South.
It's interesting to note that it's partly
in response to the American Civil War
and the Northern blockade
of Southern ships
that Egypt and India become the
world suppliers of cotton that they
will be for the rest of the 19th Century.
The other reason that England doesn't aid
the South is more of a cultural reason,
which I think is very interesting,
which is that the novel Uncle Tom's Cabin,
which we'll talk about
more in other videos,
was read really widely in England,
it was a very popular novel there.
The stage shows of Uncle
Tom's Cabin were quite common.
This novel, which in the United States,
helped to propel the Civil War by
showing Northerners how barbaric the
institution of slavery was,
also came over to England.
Because the battle of Antietam allowed
Lincoln to make the
Emancipation Proclamation,
to the citizens of England, this meant
now that the North was
an army of liberation,
that they had the choice of siding
with either Southern slaveholders,
who had been demonized
in Uncle Tom's Cabin,
or with Northerners, who were
fighting against those slaveholders.
Because of the Emancipation Proclamation,
and because of these other side issues
about the supply of
cotton, Antietam really
marks the moment where it becomes clear
that there is not going to be any
European help for the South.
That's really important, because
think of the American
movement for independence.
The reason that the United States won,
or at least one reason
that the United States won,
was because of the intervention of France.
The South knew that they needed
the help of Europe if they
were going to succeed.
Had England interceded, it's highly likely
that the South may have
won the American Civil War,
and it would have been a separate nation.
After the Battle of Antietam
and the Emancipation Proclamation,
it became clear that if the South
was going to win its
independence from the North,
it would be doing it on its own.